What I'm about to
tell you is going to be hard to believe.
Again
I've been pulled
through time
between the past and the present
and the future.
Everything is turning to.
That's right.
That everything can.
Around and around and around.
And we go.
All right.
Again.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
There's a brand new Loki Season 2
trailer with a whole bunch of new footage.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
I'm doing videos for all the episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get them or
do some special giveaway
during those episode videos
to big reminder that they'll start
right after the Ahsoka episodes are done.
I'm also doing episode videos
for that too,
so I'll post a link at the end of this
and down to the description below.
the big thing in this brand new trailer,
I mean, there's a bunch of new footage,
but the big thing is Loki at the beginning
with his voiceover
re explaining the events of season
one to Mobius and any of the other
TVA agents that are there with him
in the scene where he's speaking this.
They use a bunch of different scenes
together, cutting on top of his voice
over dialog.
Like you see him back in that time
collar inside the interrogation room.
That's probably where
some of the speech is happening days.
You see a bunch of different scenes of him
being literally pulled across time
where they call it time slipping
at the beginning of the last big trailer.
when he talks about being pulled across
time in space, though, he's talking about
the events of season one, about how he was
pulled across the timeline
and things were orchestrated by
he who remains kang this scene of him
at the very beginning with him
staring at this bright white light
might be the actual timeline like there's
a scene of Mobius in that spacesuit
walking out on the bridge
to go out to look at the timeline,
which is being framed at the end here.
I'm trying to fix things.
this might be when that's happening,
or he's witnessing
the actual timeline itself
and just kind of freaking out.
Then it jumps
to a scene of them in the hallway.
It looks like he's
still slipping through time
trying to figure out what's going on
uncontrollably.
this is them in that circular room.
It looks like they're getting ready
to either
interrogate someone
or try to actually fix that timeline
because you see Kahui clans
or a Burrows character with them.
and he's meant to be
the one that helps them fix
what's going on
with the time slipping in time, literally
unraveling, coming apart at the seams.
There are a couple different scenes
where you see that
happening to Sylvie, like she's witnessing
objects just unravel in time.
it's kind of the same effect
that's happening to Loki
when he's flipping through time
the whole idea is that time
itself is kind of broken.
And that's a consequence
of what's happening
with the Kang Multiverse War
and all the incursions
as this separate scene
after he says it's time to begin again
with all this slippage behind him,
like things are unraveling
completely behind it,
it looks like things have just gotten
really, really bad.
Wherever he is in this room,
like there was a scene in the control
room of the TVA
where you see the board
here in the mist minutes,
a sign that says,
thank you very much for your service.
Basically, like basically
you're completely screwed with everything
around them, completely unraveling in time
when he's slipping through time.
There's a scene of him sitting on this
bench in this giant warehouse here.
It's where they have the battle
with the TVA agents.
And Sylvie is there much, much later.
He slips back to the piranha store.
Basically the jetski store,
which is a big joke on
Moby, is being obsessed with jetskis
and possibly being from the nineties
because that's basically
what he was talking about in season one.
there was this perfect time
of form and function,
and it was the jet
ski during the nineties.
And when he's slipping through time, he's
kind of mimicking the motion of this
advertising blow up doll lot of people
hoping that they actually pay off the jet
ski joke during Deadpool three.
We'll see about that
because Mobius is supposed
to appear during Deadpool three, but.
I don't know that Deadpool or Wolverine
are supposed to appear in Loki Season two.
That might be a bit of a stretch
He continues his voiceover explaining
how he's been pulled through time
during Loki Season one.
While they go back to the 1890s
World's Fair.
I think this is the Chicago World's Fair
The whole idea here is
they've come to try and find the victor.
Timely version of Kang
But while this is happening,
they cut the footage from them
going back to the 1970s or the 1980s,
whichever time period this winds up being.
It's some time in the past to get the zany
character who is a comic book character.
I've done a couple of videos about him
in the past
the whole twist of his character
is that he does come from the Thor comics,
which is why he's on the Loki series,
because Loki is a Thor character.
So are a lot of Thor stuff happening here.
Vinayak was meant to be an entity.
The possessed people made them do really
crazy stuff.
And in present day of the Marvel Comics,
he possesses an actor
who is portraying the zany character
but is meant to be a fake version of zany.
the real zany act possesses him.
It makes him do all these crazy things
that he was only pretending
to do as an actor in the movie.
but at the movie premiere
there are a bunch more jokes
about fake in universe movies like
they've had in previous Marvel movies.
And some of them are also spins
on real world movies to
this is a new scene of Hunter B-15
looking at her time pad
her tempad, whichever they call it,
with a version of Miss Minutes programing,
sort of shaking her finger at her like,
no, no, no, this is broken.
You're not going to be able to use this.
they just have a funny scene of Loki
and still be with her complaining
about
how everything has gone to complete crap
when he's able to convince her
to come back to the TVA at all.
actually explain
what's going on with the McDonald's twist.
So she's actually meant to be
at a McDonald's in the 1980s,
not the 1970s, when they show up
after they've captured the zany character
because he's in that prisoner jumpsuit,
the whole idea with her character
is that after the events of season one,
she went on the run again using he who
remains tempered device like she use that
to jump through time and space
she eventually landed at this McDonald's
in the 1980s in the way that they wanted
the vibe to feel is that he had all these
different regular real world humans
coming for birthday parties, having
celebrations, just like being very happy,
eating McDonald's,
just having celebrations at this place.
and because she's spent her
entire life on the run.
She never actually experi
that kind of joy that real world
people feel when they come together
and just have parties like this.
So she wanted to be around this more.
so that's why she pretended to be a person
and just got a job here, working here
so she could be around
all these happy people.
it'd be kind of like
if you never had a birthday party
as a little kid and you suddenly started
working at a birthday store
Marvel actually turned a real life
McDonald's into a big low key activation.
But they only did it at one.
And it's in Brooklyn.
Let me know if you've actually seen this.
it's been about ten years since I've lived
in the New York City area.
Otherwise I would go myself.
but they basically turn this real world
McDonald's into the 1980s
version that you see
during the Loki episodes
with a bunch of Loki related characters
in the background,
just kind of standing there.
all the prices of all the products
are also in 1980s prices.
So you can actually get pretty cheap
McDonald's
the special sweet and sour sauce, though,
I think is meant to be
the exact same type of sweet
and sour sauce.
They just put Loki's stickers on it.
you might be able to get that
at a lot of different McDonald's, though.
But this one particular one, they just
turned into the one from the Loki series,
Then we get a new scene of what looks like
them at the beginning of season one,
where they go down to get help
from the OR Burrows character, Kahui
Quan's character and Casey
is there too, or the new version of Casey.
Remember, they had a teaser for him
at the end of season one
when Loki came back to the TVA,
the new version of the TVA
in the rebooted timeline.
supposedly
he's meant to be way more badass
than the season one version of Casey.
So we'll see.
then they have another scene
where the actual timeline is,
and it looks like it's completely
exploding at the seams here at the end.
But then in this next scene,
this is actually pretty curious
because it looks like
Loki or Mobius is explaining what they're
about to do, trying to fix the timeline
with the spacesuit in a little model
in in the background zoom in enhance
this looks just like Victor Timely Kang
that they're explaining things to
so either they wind up capturing Victor
Timely Kang or they convince him
at the world's Fair to come help them fix
the timeline this scene.
Looks like
it's happening at the actual TVA,
because most of the scenes
that we've seen with Victor Timely Kang
before have only been back in the 1890s
World Fair.
this scene of Renslayer
looks like she's making one
of those TVA pruning devices,
but it's old timey technology.
Basically the same thing though.
Like it does the same thing
she might be trying to protect.
Victor Timely
Kang at the end of season one
when she escaped, she did so
on the orders of he who remains king
like he told her to get out of there.
Not totally clear
what his plan for her was,
but it seems like those plans
have sent her to the 1890s World's Fair
and she might be there to protect him
from Loki in Mobius
they're couple of scenes of him that
we saw in the previous trailers of him
just demonstrating his time travel device
to all the people at the world's Fair
kind of in a Nikola Tesla
kind of way That's meant to be kind of
the vibe of the character,
like he's the Nikola Tesla version of Kang
they've a funny scene of Loki and Sylvie
teaming up again, using their powers
together to defeat all the different TVA
agents with a big blast of magic.
the thing about the two of them is that
even though they are basically meant
to be versions of the same character,
they have different powers.
The whole idea
that Sylvie is meant to be based
a little bit on the Enchantress
is character in Lady Loki from the comics.
That's
why her powers are a little bit different,
a little bit
more like the Enchantress Powers.
there was actually a promo recently
for Loki season two that they did,
but it was animated
and it did have a version of a moira,
the actual Enchantress character.
But I'm not expecting to see her
during Loki season two.
I think this was just meant to be
a funny promo that they did
with Marvel Snap for Loki Season two.
Lucky.
Lucky. What are you up to now?
Oh, chicks.
God. Will with
the bishop is bred with the loss
of the spark of the beast
causing trouble for
the Iraqi army.
You take it for you.
No one can get a chance
to take it to the trouble twisting.
Trouble?
They won't even have trouble. In
so many times over the years, every time
there's been a new Thor project,
everybody always asks. It's like anytime
there's a new Thor movie.
Even when Thor the Dark World came out,
people were like,
Do you think that they're going to have
a more of the Enchantress in this one,
To be fair, though, when they did
Loki season one, they were like,
Oh yeah, we definitely based her a lot
on the Enchantress character,
even though she is
just meant to be another version of Loki.
that's
why one of her powers is literally messing
with people's minds, enchanting them,
so to speak.
there's some new Victor timely voiceover
where he talks about around and around.
We go with them
cutting a couple of different scenes
together during the new ones.
It just seems like it's them in the middle
of trying to fix the timeline
with scenes of them back in the 1970s,
trying to take down the Xenia character
Sylvie back at the actual record store
before she's left with Loki.
It seems like witnessing time unravel,
like objects
unraveling in time
not sure what this device is, though.
Like in this warehouse
that you see in the other scenes.
You see Victor timely
hold up an old timey looking device.
And it looks like him
just trying to construct parts of his time
travel devices.
the letters in the Loki season
two logo switching backwards to fours
is just meant to be a play
on the idea of Loki
being pulled across time in time,
completely coming apart at the seams.
leave it to Loki and Sylvie
to completely break all of time in space.
normally
you blame something like that on Deadpool,
but I think he's only messing
with the 838 universe.
They might spin it in
something bigger though,
because of all the delays
with the strikes,
they might have actually tried
to turn it into a much bigger thing
They'll be a couple more Loki Season
two trailers before episode one comes out.
Of course, I'll do more videos
as we get more footage.
if you spotted any Easter eggs
or references in this trailer
that I didn't talk about in the video
or my previous trailer videos,
just write them below in the comments.
my bullets.
Okay.
Episode four Video will post after
they release it, so click here for that.
I think the link as soon as I post it and
click here for all my other Loki Season
two trailer videos and Easter Eggs.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.